but you you take a scene like the
the christoph waltz and and how he
builds elita sort of in the image of his
daughter at least his idealization of
of who his daughter could have been and
the
dad teenage daughter thing worked for me
but she's not a teenager she's 300 years
old mark anyway yep go ahead sorry well
i mean baby yoda's 50 and we still call
him a child
like it's it it just it it felt grounded
in reality whether it's the 1500s or the
2000s or the 2500s
that a a father is going to be
shepherding a daughter for a period of
time and then eventually they have to go
out in the world and you give them the
warnings hey try to stay away from
motorball
that's the sky people we live down here
don't worry about getting up there just
have a nice life down here and best of
luck and to see him struggle with that
it's like that you know foundation for a
better life commercial where the
the girl's going off to college and she
stops the car and runs back to hug her
dad one more time
that i felt that i felt that wow
all right and mark you have a long
lost profession as a lifetime movie
podcaster
because wow
it's not a shot it's the truth that is
some schmaltz
john you know what i thought she was
going to say i thought you were talking
about two turtle doves knowledgeably
that's what she said go ahead i thought
jacqueline was going to say mark you
have a long lost profession as a father
and i was like well i'm out
[Laughter]
well but at least in those movies the
com the companions are comparable in
terms of quality and intelligence and
knowledge
but in this movie lolita is so far ahead
of hugo
it's insulting and it's this trope that
we see multiple times
in science fiction and to be fair and i
probably will get pilloried for this but
in the manga and anime stuff you see
this
ordinary dudes discover the young
just built or just created a beautiful
female sexualized character and because
he's the first dude she comes across
she falls in love with him he guides her
through the world and she never moves
past him which is why i think
her is such a great film because she
moves
past him she moves moves past joaquin
she moves out into a bigger world
and elita never does elita is still tied
to this dude in fact to the point
where she tries to give this ordinary
dude her literally
her heart that's the unobtainium moment
of the movie let me put it
on the nose what i'm doing and then with
all her talent
she's like let me go hunting so i could
get you those ninety thousand dollars
so you can get to this guy and it's like
it's even this dude is like when you
stop doing nice things for everybody for
god's sake
you're gonna get abused so it's this
kind of thing that
that just drives me nuts she's so far
ahead of him it's the aquaman
issue she's so far smarter and more
talented and more
of able to do everything but she's got
to elevate this dude and it drives me
nuts all of dc you don't see that trevor
was not a slouch but compared to an
amazon
dude was like like no no dude was like
that dude on
tinder that you're like oh he's cute but
he hasn't had a job in four years that's
basically steve trevor you know what i
mean
hugo is adding the one component that i
don't care how tough of a murder robot
you are the
penis can't forge in fire and that is
humanness passion
you